[Applaudissements]
dix mille à savoir les échos je peux
marcher là comme ça alors écoutez il ya
un truc qui le télex ouargla pour moi il
est très spécial parce que moi je suis
de ouargla mes parents mon père mon
grand père mon arrière grand père depuis
des centaines d'années on edward g donc
ce soir c'est vous qui êtes mes invités
[Applaudissements]
deuxième chose je fais les interventions
hamdoulilah quasiment toutes les
semaines
partout sur le globe et c'est la
première fois que dans une salle où
j'interviens il ya autant de noirs et je
suis très content je suis très très fier
vraiment
je me sens chez moi pour une fois bon
alors rentrons dans le vif du sujet on
est parti là on est prévenu quand ils
m'ont appelé pour faire le pbx ouargla
ils m'ont dit le sujet c'est demain
commence aujourd'hui je me suis dit
c'est pas intéressés par l'intellect
c'est un james bond je me suis dit ça
mais ça fait un peu comme les titres
tomorrow never die
ça fait ce qu'il faut c'est fait et là
je me suis imaginé je me suis dit voir
là vous rendez compte un james bond en
algérie avec biyouna comme james bond
girl alcoolique
la classe vous imaginez daniel craig
avec un téléphone condor
et et avec un abonnement mobilis daniel
craig
machar là ok donc je me suis dit ce truc
là il faut absolument que j'y aille faut
absolument que j'y aille donc je suis
venu et je suis très fier d'être avec
vous alors moi je vais vous donner mon
histoire de manière très simple surtout
que les profils qu'on a aujourd'hui sont
juste extraordinaire dont je n'ai pas
passé beaucoup de temps vous expliquez
moi j'ai fini mes études à oxford
je suis rentré dans une salle des
marchés où j'ai fait des produits
structurés pendant quelques années j'ai
fait de la finance de la haute finance
complexe et au bout de quatre ans je me
suis dit je vais revenir en algérie
c'était en 2002 et mon boulot quand je
suis revenu ça a été de valoriser
l'excellence algérienne mes
grands-parents n'a fille tia rajaona a
fait une gousse un partout il avait des
plantations depuis très longtemps et
j'ai repris et gnl cash daudet et j'ai
introduit l'agriculture biologique en
algérie en 2002 on est les premiers nous
en 2002 à avoir monté une entreprise qui
nous permettait d' exporter des denrées
alimentaires avec le logo ab ya presque
quinze ans déjà
donc on a monté cette boîte dieu nous
qui finalement à travailler à la
valorisation de l'excellence algérienne
parce qu'on a fait les dates qu'on a
vendu le aux quatre coins du monde
des dates qu'on a vendu très cher on a
travaillé sur des produits d'une huile
d'olive
on a valorisé l'huile d'olive kabyle
dans aux quatre coins du monde
on a travaillé sur les fruits sur les
légumes et tous a certifié biologique
depuis une quinzaine d'années et depuis
une quinzaine et bien au bout de quinze
ans au bout de 13 ans j'en ai eu marre
parce que moi la balle j'étais plutôt un
matheux et au bout de 13 ans je me suis
dit que une autre bataille m'attendais
l'autre bataille m'attendait et gémit
bio nour entre parenthèses et j'ai monté
une dream team g
réunis tous les plus brillant
mathématicien que je connais tous les
polytechniciens tous les centraliens
tous les gens de berkeley tous les gens
de stanford
tous les gens de harvard tous les gens
de normale sup en france qui sont en
mathématiques très très fort j'ai réuni
toutes les têtes de réseau gérés unis
par exemple françois bieber qui est
l'entrepreneur de l'année en 2011
j'ai réuni jacques vincent jacques
vincent qui est l'ancien numéro 2 de
danone monde
j'ai réuni des grands philosophes comme
edgar morin et j'ai monté une entreprise
qui s'appelle big mama en france et qui
fait du big data qui fait du
développement algorithmique dire que
notre métier en france c'est de
fabriquer les robots qui aujourd'hui
vont enfin les robots informatiques qui
vont bouleverser votre vie d'aujourd'hui
et de demain alors je vais vous donner
quelques exemples très très simple
aujourd'hui de manière un peu légère on
est capable par des robots qu'on
programme de savoir de qui vous allez
tomber amoureux
et c'est moi
c'est non mais je plaisante mais en fait
on les tue c'est très sérieux
aujourd'hui la programmation est là
aujourd'hui les algorithmes sont
capables de savoir presque mieux vous
quelle est la probabilité que vous soyez
attaché à quelqu'un ou pas alors
attention
nous parlons de probabilité nous sommes
des mathématiciens la certitude et dans
les mains d'al mahra ça c'est très
important
mais aujourd'hui quand vous gérez des
groupes d'hommes et que vous savez que
dans ce groupe d'hommes il ya 90 % qui
vont faire ça qu'ils vont faire ça ou
qui vont faire ça à tel moment à la
limite vous n'avez pas besoin de savoir
précisément qui va faire quoi ce qui est
important c'est de savoir que 90 % vont
faire ça et ça c'est très important donc
aujourd'hui ont effectivement nous
travaillons sur ce qu'on appelle des
algorithmes de recommandations qui
permettent aux grands sites de
rencontres européen de savoir qui va
être attiré par qui on est capable par
ailleurs de prédire sur des chaînes de
production industrielle
quelle pièce va casser à quel moment on
est capable aujourd'hui de savoir qui
peut tomber malade et de quoi à quel
moment on est capable aujourd'hui de
faire des choses encore plus
extraordinaire on en est capable de
travailler sur des problématiques de
diagnostic médical vraiment aujourd'hui
qu'un médecin qui est un humain au
moment où il prend votre dossier médical
au moment où ils regardent votre dossier
médical
kobe nitivement cérébralement il est
capable de traiter sept ou huit aspects
de votre dossier simultanément quand
c'est un bon médecin aujourd'hui vous
avez des algorithmes qui sont capables
de traiter 30 aspects de votre dossier
au même moment la médecine telle que
vous la connaissez aujourd'hui telle
qu'on la connaît en occident telle qu'on
la connaît en afrique tel qu'on l'a
connu en algérie parce qu'on a de très
bons médecins en algérie cette médecine
telle qu'on la connaît d'ici 10 15 ou 20
ans alors un complètement disparu
quelques vous la connaissez la manière
dont vous circulez dans vos voitures ça
va disparaître la manière dont vous
rencontrez des gens ça disparaît alors
on me dit oui vous allez me dire oui
algérie peut-être que en algérie
peut-être que nous on est un peu loin de
tout ça je vais vous donner deux
exemples qui sont très importants qui
sont dans votre vie aujourd'hui
quotidiennent aujourd'hui qui
structurent votre vie aujourd'hui quand
vous allez sur google et que vous tapez
cherchera dans google la liste qui sort
c'est une liste qui est piloté par un
algorithme d'ailleurs que google chine
google a mis google comme on nous a dit
ce matin c'est quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui
décide par un outil qu'on appelle des
algorithmes de ce que vous allez voir un
moment où vous faites une recherche et
si je décide de ce que vous voyez au
moment de ce que vous faites votre
recherche finalement je décide de ce que
vous choisissez plus loin vous avez tous
facebook quand vous ouvrez votre
facebook et que vous allez voir dans vos
amis les recommandations d'amis vous
croyez vraiment que les recommandations
elles sont faites par hasard sont pas
fait par hasard elles sont faites et
elles sont pilotées par un algorithme et
c'est algorithmique et bien entendu
stratégiquement a pour objectif de
maximiser les intérêts de l'entreprise
qui développe ses sacs de riz donc voilà
aujourd'hui on vit en réalité quelque
chose qui est une révolution
on vit un moment où l'humanité notre
relation à l'humanité est en train de
changer
et si on fais pas très attention les
problèmes que nous avons aujourd'hui et
qui sont de gros problèmes vont ne
seront que des problèmes négligeable par
rapport à ce qu'on aura aujourd'hui
militairement si on développe à des
systèmes qui tiennent compte de ce genre
de logique ça servira plus à rien
d'acheter des sukhoï 35 ou des mig-29 un
bon alors vous allez me dire oui mais tu
es bien gentil avec les histoires mais
c'est quoi le rapport avec les dates
moi quand on m'a demandé de faire un
quand on m'a demandé de faire un quand
moi j'ai dit à ma mère que j'allais
faire de la big data ma mère m'a fait
une très jolie plaisanterie elle m'a dit
à un tu vas faire de la datar alors tu
as fait tu es passé de la date à la date
à l'humour des mamans et après comme ça
ah ouais
et en fait à la pâte au parce que moi à
chaque fois que j'interviens dans toutes
les conférences ont dit oui mais leur
âge
franchement c'est quoi le rapport entre
la date et la data c'est quoi ta
cohérence c'est quoi ton truc c'est quoi
ta juste pété un plomb tu as juste non
et en fait c'est peut-être une des
questions les plus ingrates que j'ai
jamais entendu ces ingrats et vous savez
pourquoi c'est un drag en question parce
que l'humanité telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui telle qu'on la conçoit
aujourd'hui elle c'est à la dette
qu'elle a par rapport aux fruits qui est
la date vous moment-là ça à la wii ou
pas vous n'existe riez pas s'ils
n'avaient pas eu des milliers d'années
où les gens avaient mangé des dates
pendant des milliers d'années
on a vécu on a grandi on s'est
développée on s'est mariés on a écrit on
s'est instruit grâce à la batte aux
fruits à la date et aujourd'hui on
oublie parce qu'effectivement on avait
plein d'autres aujourd'hui on peut
manger n'importe quoi on peut passer
toute une vie sans manger une date la
rall mais à une époque les dates c'est
ce qui a fait la vie
notre prophète alors celle là ne jurait
que sont nos juristes afrique sujet je
n'aurais pas mais nous nous as a passé
des heures des journées à nous expliquer
les bienfaits de la date et on oublie et
les dates en leur temps ont rendu la vie
possible à tout le monde et même le
suédois gurria stockholm grand blond aux
yeux bleus lui aussi il doit sa vie aux
dates parce qu'à une époque lui il était
africain
tout le monde est africain façon tout le
monde vient d'ici voilà la vérité et
quand on parle aujourd'hui des dates à
la date à la réalité est là pour moi mon
équation personnelle à moi c'est que les
données d'aujourd'hui d'aujourd'hui sont
les date d'hier les données
permettre aux humains de vivre mieux en
réalité et c'est ça qui est très
important et pour moi la transition en
réalité elle était hyper naturel
j'ai travaillé sur des dap qui étaient
en fait des choses naturelles qui était
le fruit de mon histoire le fruit de mon
identité je me suis retrouvé dans les
data parce que c'est la continuité
naturelle
tout simplement et alors vous allez me
dire oui mais la dja c'est bien ton
entreprise tes grands noms des grandes
universités des grandes conférences des
algorithmes des travaux pour les grandes
entreprises c'est très très bien mais en
algérie tu fais quoi
c'est un différend en algérie et ben en
algérie depuis un an on a monté big mama
algérie parce que depuis parce que j'en
ai marre qu'on me dise que les algériens
sont pas sérieux j'en ai marre qu'on me
dise que l'on n'a pas d'algériens prix
nobel j'en ai marre qu'on me dise qu'on
n'a pas d'algériens médaille fields j'en
ai marre je suis fatigué ça evron que
j'ai monté cette boîte pour faire en
sorte que rapidement nos mathématicien
qui dont certains sont très très bons
puisse avoir un lieu d'expression est un
lieu de développement
je veux que en algérie on puisse
rapidement avoir des unités de gens qui
vont développer nos algorithmes nos
outils and non mécanique de souveraineté
et si on n'a pas vous très honnêtement
on peut mémé ou pas mais mais on peut
apprécier ou pas apprécié mais très
honnêtement déroule y prier pour qu'on
réussisse et si c'est pas moi qui
réussit prier pour que quelqu'un
d'autres réussissent parce que si a pas
des algériens qui sont capables
aujourd'hui de sortir de cette logique
de revente aux deux chocolats
ambassadeurs de tri malades à aa2 soit
deux francs six sous et pas capable de
valoriser et de fabriquer des vrais
mathématicien des vrais pilotes
d'algorithmes des vrais aujourd'hui un
vrai savoir faire que nous pouvons avoir
parce que nos mathématicien sont très
très bons si on n'est pas capable de
faire ça dans 15 ans on aura perdu toute
forme de souveraineté
on aura perdu toute forme d'indépendance
parce que l'enjeu il est là il me reste
quatre minutes pour vous expliquer à un
truc qui est très important salut moi je
suis né en algérie je suis né à
bologhine je suis parti en france assez
tôt mais je suis né à bologhine je suis
algérien je suis algérien depuis
toujours c'est ma seule nationalité
d'ailleurs et ce qui est important pour
moi c'est bien comprendre que j'ai
beaucoup souffert de la guerre d'algérie
même si je suis né en 1973 il j'ai
beaucoup souffert parce que je suis né à
une époque où les gens étaient encore
marqués dans leur sens et moi ma mère
elle a beaucoup souffert de ça mais ma
famille on a beaucoup souffert de ça et
je trouve que ne pas faire tout ce qu'on
peut pour maintenir notre souveraineté
et pour maintenir notre liberté
c'est finalement craché sur notre
héritage c'est ça dont ces enjeux
vraiment c'est nous aujourd'hui on est
là on se plaint on est là on se plaint à
juste titre il ya beaucoup de choses qui
vont pas en train de cracher sur ça mais
souvenez vous que quand vos grands
parents avaient notre âge il était au
maquis ont leur tirer dessus on violer
leurs femmes pauvres pour certains donc
aujourd'hui ce qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui c'est quand même une
situation plus confortable et notre
devoir à nous notre devoir
si on veut continuer le travail de nos
glorieux martyrs
c'est de faire tout ce qu'on peut pour
maintenir et restaurer notre liberté et
je vais vous dire quelque chose savaient
- j'entends en france on dit oui les
algériens vous êtes patriotes algériens
vous êtes nationaliste pas vrai c'est un
peu vrai un peu mais c'est pas ça qui
est le plus vrai ce qui est le plus vrai
vraiment c'est qu'on aime la liberté
on s'est battu pour notre liberté comme
peu de gens sur terre se sont battus
pour leur liberté et notre enjeu nous la
jeunesse algérienne
c'est d'aller aussi loin en tout cas de
faire tout ce qui est possible pour
continuer
travail qui a été fait avant et si on
continue pas ce travail on n'aura même
pas le droit de se plaindre si on n'est
pas à la hauteur du notre héritage
on n'aura même pas le droit de se
plaindre et aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre et de manière assez
inattendue et c'est ce qui a fait en
fait en réalité que j'ai monté big mama
et que j'ai aujourd'hui je travaille
avec les meilleurs et qu'aujourd'hui mon
objectif c'est de faire que certains
parmi ses meilleurs soient rapidement
algérien donc bien entendu vous envoyez
nous louvre c'est si vous pensez que
vous êtes bon en mathématiques que vous
avez un avenir en algorithmes et nous
attendons votre cv avec impatience mais
mon en jeu à moi c'est de vous dire que
comme on vous l'a expliqué toute la
journée comme tous les speakers vous
l'ont dit avec beaucoup de talent il ya
un moment où il faut faire sa part
il ya un moment il faut rentrer dans son
périmètre il ya un moment où il faut
tenir compte de son périmètre
il ya un moment où il faut faire preuve
de deux certitudes de soi ya un moment
où il faut travailler sur l'éducation de
ses enfants
y'a un moment et tout ça c'est des
outils de souveraineté c'est des outils
qu'ils maintiendront notre liberté et
c'est ça d'ailleurs que les mois je vous
dire c'est ça que les gens nous
jalousent
c'est ça que les gens nous jalousent
quand vous allez partout dans le monde
il ya encore des gens qui vous disaient
c'est vrai que vous avez battu les
français c'est vrai avec des pelles et
des pioches des fauves ou les aider et
ça les gens ils ont su qu'on ne soit
capable de faire ça donc moi ce que je
vous dis très honnêtement
peut-être qu'il ya des choses qu'on peut
faire peut-être que des choses qu'on
peut pas aujourd'hui il ya quelque chose
qui existe qui s'appelle la technologie
qui est à notre portée et qui peut nous
permettre rapidement et finalement pour
plus de moyens de passer à une étape
bien supérieure et de résoudre
finalement bien des problèmes dans le
pays
aujourd'hui à des technologies des
algorithmes qui peuvent permettre de
résoudre enfin pas de résoudre mais de
diminuer le chômage de manière
extraordinaire il ya des algorithmes
aujourd'hui qui permettent de savoir
comment on produit de l'énergie
comment on dépense beaucoup moins
d'énergie pour le même résultat
erin le bret qui permettent de savoir où
est ce que on va chercher du pétrole
pour qu'on cherche du pétrole là plutôt
colle à ce savoir faire
si on ne développe pas si on ne comprend
pas tout de suite on risque notre
liberté
donc à bon entendeur salut j'ai été ravi
de passer quelques minutes avec vous il
me reste neuf secondes avant de vous dis
enfin deux avant la fin de mai 18
minutes merci beaucoup et bamako
[Applaudissements]